this is Joe Biden moving the goal posts
when did Joe Biden know that he was for
gay marriage it was like 1960 it's wild
uh well take a look
for you Mr President is you codified uh
support for same-sex marriage and
interracial marriages like like ours I'm
curious what your Evolution was like on
marriage equality and what the federal
government might be able to do to
protect lgbtq Americans especially trans
kids who are dealing with all these
regressive state laws that are popping
up right now
I can remember exactly where my Epiphany
was okay I hadn't thought much about it
tell you the truth and I was a I was a
senior in high school and my dad was
dropping me off I remember about to get
out of the car and I looked to my right
in two well-dressed men in suits kissed
each other
I mean they give each other a kiss and
then one went looked like he was heading
to the DuPont building one looked like
he had the Hercules Corporation building
and I never forget I turn to look to my
dad he said Joey it's simple they love
each other
Joe Biden is claiming that in 1961
that he was for gay marriage 1961 he was
for a gay marriage he is so enlightened
Joe Biden also I don't know what the
hell Cal Penn is talking about that Joe
Biden somehow codified interracial
marriage but okay put that aside also
for some reason calpen is very
interested in having young boys chop
their genitals off or young girls chop
their breasts off without having any uh
development in their brain to know what
they're doing with their lives but okay
that's sort of leftism 101 right now
mutilation of the genitals is very high
on their hierarchy of important things
but Joe Biden again is saying in that
1961 he was for gay marriage well that's
quite bizarre because it took us about
10 seconds to find this from 2006.
I can't believe the American people
can't see through this reality have a
law the Defense of Marriage Act we've
all voted not or I voted and others said
look marriage is between a man and a
woman and states must respect that
nobody's violated that law there's been
no challenge to that law why do we need
a constitutional amendment marriage is
between a man and a woman what's the
game going on here did you support gay
marriage no Barack Obama support
redefining from a from a civil side what
constitutes marriage
so upsetting guys because I I believe in
Joe Biden I believe that in 1961 he was
in high school and saw two gentlemen two
well-dressed gentleman kiss and thought
I will fight for gay rights after I
leave the Jewish temple this morning and
I get out and I have uh sandwiches with
my Puerto Rican friends and I also grew
up in the uh in the hood and all of the
other nonsensical things he makes up but
somehow 50 years later he was still
fighting against gay marriage it's all
so confusing
[Music]
good